can you recruit players from outside of
bedford or when you're in the lower
levels can you only get people from
inside of uh the town no you're getting
from anywhere all right and then is this
like uh recruiting kind of like college
football here in america where they like
you go and you visit them at their home
and you try to convince them to come
play for you and they can pick from any
team or is it pretty much like people
come and try out and then you just pick
the best ones
but basically you you the managers
usually know the players you want so you
just you have to you have to do
something called a seven day approach
where you write to them say who you want
to speak to and and then you just have
to make them an offer but um
but no it's not like what tends
happening in uk football when you think
of the higher leagues is the players
start playing in the youth setups they
might be at 10 12 years old and they
work their way through the academies
some eventually make it to the first
team others get let go and go down the
leagues
all right perfect that's exactly the
answer i wanted to hear i have a
proposition for you can i be head
recruiter like i'll facetime the people
and be like listen you really got to go
play for real bedford so that when you
get to the epl i can say that it's
because of me
no
all right walk us through the
merchandise strategy in terms of uh you
guys have this merchandise coming out in
january i think it is what is so special
about doing it for you guys given uh how
the team may have done it previously or
other teams at the level 10. i mean our
team doesn't really sell much because
they're just they're so small but even
next door bedford town you know they do
really well but then they'll maybe sell
300 shirts a season
i mean you think of these bitcoiners i'd
be surprised if i sell less than three
thousand and if i can sell ten thousand
every ten thousand shirts i sell i make
about three hundred thousand pound
profit then on top of that you've got
t-shirts you have flags you got mugs so
i would hope i would hope i could do
half a million in revenue to the
bitcoiners that might be ambitious but
that's the target but you know if you
take sponsorships if you take
memberships you take live streaming you
take shirt sales you know that could
support the club in these early days
while we don't really have gate receipts
you know well we've only got maybe
50 people coming into a game but as we
go through the leagues you might 50
might become 500 might become a thousand
and then you can rely on the matchday
revenues as well
how much are the t-shirts going to be
sold for
so uh i think that the the jerseys like
what you call the jerseys we call the
shirt i think it's going to be somewhere
between
50 and 60 pounds unless you live in
bedford if you live in bedford we're
going to do it like 30 pounds 35 pounds
all right so 50 or 60 pounds how much is
that in the u.s
that's 70 80 70 or 80 dollars
jesus christ all right i'll make you a
deal i was gonna buy a lot more but you
you got uh expensive prices over there
i'll buy uh what would you say 80
i'll buy whatever a thousand dollars
worth of jerseys are whatever i'm not a
public mathematician uh
or a thousand dollars worth i'll buy
them you ship them to me and then we'll
give them to the guests when they come
into the studio we'll give them each one
under
the condition that they tweet out and
they say
i'm only a real bedford fc fan because
pomp made me
whatever man we get [ __ ] in one
of course well i mean he sits and hangs
out in puerto rico the guy looks like
he's uh uh still in his 30s he's got a
tan slicked back hair he he obviously
needs a jersey
man let's do it as long as you gotta
wear one on this show as well of course
that's easy peter so going to using
bitcoin as a
like a unit of exchange in a unit of
account
how do you think about if you would ever
price something in the merchandise store
in sats for example to let people pay in
that unit
look we'll let people pay in uh whatever
currency they want whether it's uh
dollars pounds or bitcoin we want no
[ __ ] coins but
any of those but everything will be
priced in fear like
the pound is our unit of account running
the business
the uh but we will hold bitcoin in our
treasury long term but you can't you
can't use uh bitcoin as a unit account
at the moment you can't run a business
like that not not something like this
it's yeah it's too volatile but
uh we will allow you know i'm talking to
one of the payment processors now about
uh
managing all our uh bitcoin transactions
for for our merchandise
peter have you seen the show ted lasso
of course man have you not seen my name
on twitter
no but is this what it's going to be
like are you hiring an american football
coach
what about a college one
nice
are you gonna is the manager in trouble
like is he is his job on the line here
if he doesn't win i mean at the end of
the season yeah i mean you know the
reamer every year is promotion um
and
every manager will give be given a
budget that should enable promotions if
they don't get promotion yeah they're
they're in trouble okay but this is not
real life ted lasso just to confirm
he's no it's not realistic this is
this is i mean this is serious for me
like we have a lot of fun as well but
like this is seriously
like mike i live in the town of 174 000
people pop and there's two teams with
two towns with premier league teams
we've got a smaller population than us
and we're in we have teams in the eighth
and tenth tier we should have at least a
team in the fourth tier and we've never
had it we've never had a football league
club so like this is a big deal for me
i've been telling my dad since i was 14
i'm gonna do this and then suddenly i'm
in a position to try it which is amazing
but um
but yeah we were we're gonna do this man
what what did you do usually when a
billionaire comes on the podcast i ask
him like what did you do the second that
you found out you're a billionaire and
mark cuban told me he got naked and did
a happy dance put his clothes back on i
went back to work what did you do when
you realized you were gonna get the team
oh girl that's a good question um i mean
if you listen to my podcast you not only
ask good questions
i mean i don't really use your show as
inspiration
for how to run a podcast um
i don't know if you really do have the
best questions i think you have the
second best question i think lily has
the best question how good is lily she's
good boy answer my question see this is
this is you
skating
you know i don't remember what i did i
don't i can't nothing special i think
the better question will be when we get
promoted what did i do
um what will you do
i'm just going to get really [ __ ]
drunk
so when is the next chance to get
promoted
let me tell you well so it's this season
so i mean
we are outside of the playoffs so i've
given the managers a budget to try and
get playoffs if we don't make it so be
it like the way i think about it it's a
bonus this we start next season in terms
of like the manager has to get us
promoted then i get us promoted this
season you know we took we took over
halfway through we haven't had a chance
to sign players let me tell you
something super interesting pop though
that's happened because of this
the weight between games is painfully
slow
like all i'm thinking about i've never
even had this with the teams i support
all i'm thinking about right now is okay
we've got a game on third i want that
now like i cannot think about anything
else i'm working on this like 16 hours a
day
and when you're working on it for 16
hours a day what are you doing like are
you
spending time with the uh managers what
like what are you doing
well i [ __ ] love you
for those who are only listening he just
poured uh what appears to be red wine
into a water drinking glass cup and is
now sipping it go ahead
i am
i've set up the website i'm registering
people's the international supports club
i'm
working with the designers on the merch
i'm trying to find a merch manufacturer
i am you know liaising with the
management on budgets i am working on
legal i'm trying to appoint a financial
director i'm winding people up on
twitter like this a [ __ ] endless list
of things to get done
like if i show i'll have to show you
sometime and i can't tell you a whole
story in person one day but there's just
so much to do running a football club
and you know i want to breathe this
absolute culture of professionalism like
absolute professionalism for it but i
need to get a team around me right they
don't have a team because they don't
have a budget yeah but now you have a
budget you can go ahead and you can
actually execute
yeah so i've got a financial director
lined up i've got a chief exec lined up
i've got a vice chair lined up i've got
an operations person lined up like i've
got a team lined up um and we're going
to run it like an absolutely slick
professional operation because it needs
to be a successful business
you know to have the budgets to buy the
best players to sign the best managers
you need to have the budget and i want
every season for the next six seasons i
want to target 20 higher budget than any
team in our division
the only thing that you didn't mention
that you need in there is you need some
american co-owners and i know three guys
who you might be able to convince to do
that so uh send me the pitch deck get on
my schedule and we'll talk
dude we'll do it i mean i'll be back
over in uh i'm gonna be over uh of
february come and see you all right
yeah
i don't want to wait till february
because i don't want you to start
winning games and think you guys are
good i want you when you first buy them
and being like oh man we got a lot of
help yeah if you start winning games you
think you're gonna get promoted then
also the price goes up i don't want that
you know what i want to do is get a
friendly against into miami
what
into miami the team oh yeah
i got a better idea i saw someone in the
chat say that we should set up like an
exhibition match that's what a friendly
is with no with the el salvador national
team
dude
and we should do it in miami we should
bring el salvador's national team we
should bring real bedford fc play it in
miami don't call me a marketing genius
but if that happens i want to do the
opening kick
i want to do
like the ceremonial kick i'll be on
midfield
kelly
yeah get on the horn
me and blue kelly can do a shootout to
see who's uh who gets to do the opening
kick
no i thought i tweeted at a bouquet i
said let's uh i want to fight i want
bedford to go to el salvador and play in
the el salvador national stadium against
the south salvador team we should call
it the volcano cup
that's great
all right that was pretty that's pretty
good that might be better than the miami
thing
yeah the volcano cup you only want to be
in miami because you're a lazy
i mean if we're going to go ahead and
just pick destinations and i'm in charge
like down the street we got a stadium
like let's just go there
yeah man well i i i you know what i
think this is a big thing for bitcoin
like we make all these jokes i really
think this is a good thing for bitcoin i
think we can really communicate the
benefits of you know sound money and why
sports teams should consider the thing
the thing is i don't i think it's
different in the u.s u.s sports is set
up a lot better structurally than uk
sports in some ways or football but so
many of these teams are going bust man
like derby county
trying to find a new owner yeah i think
they've just been deducting nine points
already have been deducted points these
clubs are always losing money and
failing and we can actually create
something here that's not built on debt
that's built on capital accumulation
because we run a bitcoin standard and by
the time we've done this like yeah give
this four or five years when we're
kicking ass we've got this growing
treasury everyone's gonna be like what
what happened there how did this happen
now we were like we [ __ ] told you i
told you this is what we were gonna do